maybe there's something else you can get
into we know fall is in the air and the
weather's starting to cool down so the
sights and sounds and smells of the
season are starting to settle in
of course we're talking about scents
like pumpkin spice it's everywhere but
did you know you can make them at home
our Heather Mills talked with a holistic
health expert about do-it-yourself
aromatherapy
Amy it is all about DIY so let's talk
about how we can kind of spice up our
fall routine I'm gonna make a recipe
from my new book The Healing home or
room by room guide to Positive Vibes and
it is the the dining room Dynamic
spreads we're going to make that and
we're going to use that in the dining
room and we're going to add an autumnal
flare oh okay let's dive in so we're
gonna it's fun with aromatherapy there
are some scents that we can combine that
don't always seem like they would go
together and then they smell amazing so
we are going to take a bottle with
spring water or distilled water your
choice you could use purified water as
well so you have your spray bottle you
can choose whatever size you want a size
like this is about three to four ounces
I don't fill it up quite all the way so
it's like three and a half ounces so for
that case each of your oils you can put
about five drops so from the healing
home our Dynamic Spritz for the dining
room which is designed to encourage
socialization we use five drops of lemon
and then you would have five drops of
grapefruit essential oil and keep in
mind with essential oils a little goes a
long way then our third oil for this
Divine dining room Dynamic Spritz is
Clary Sage and that is very Dynamic so
that is the recipe from the healing Home
Room by room guide to positive vibe
great now if we want to take this in a
really autumnal Direction then we can go
to the next level and add a really neat
essential oil that goes great with these
others and it is essential oil of nutmeg
okay I've got some nutmeg and you take
that to a completely autumnal level if
you want to get extra autumna then you
can put clove essential oil that is our
one of our strongest oils you need two
drops of clove very little flow because
clove is uh pretty potent okay keep it
in your two drops of clove and then you
pop on your cover
and you shake and then you can use this
as a air freshener perfect and then
Spritz and because this is a hundred
percent therapeutic grade has to be
therapeutic grade essential oils and
these are organic you could use this as
a perfume